okay so I know Formula One and NASCAR
are not the first thing that come to
mind when you think of eSports
but recently 1.3 million people watched
fake cars go around a fake track and a
professional f1 driver is blowing up on
Twitch so just what the hell is going on
with sim racing
okay so f1 and NASCAR are two sports
that your weird uncle Randy probably
likes so in March both Formula One and
NASCAR cancelled upcoming races due to
health concerns over kovat 19 and pretty
quickly someone realized hey people love
real cars going fast
they'll probably love this [ __ ] too now
from the NASCAR Pro Invitational series
which is a series of tournaments
featuring current and retired drivers
that meant throwing a race on Fox Sports
we're over a million people watched it
live which apparently makes it the most
watched eSports program on TV ever now
for Formula One a big part of its recent
popularity is due to this guy Lando
Norris he's a professional f1 driver who
races for McLaren who also streams on
Twitch and he's broken to a hundred
thousand concurrent viewers multiple
times on March 11th he drove in the not
the Australian Grand Prix and actually
broke f1 streaming record as 70,000
people watched him crash into other
drivers and eventually hit disqualified
and despite being a professional f1
driver who drives at speeds that would
probably cause me to [ __ ] my pants you
can't help but smile when you notice
that he's nervous because he's streaming
to so many people oh I'm gonna notice
now that I am when I Drive the actual
car a week later he drove in the Bahrain
Grand Prix where he actually called
other popular racer match for stopping
for advice and people are freaking out
on stream but my my chat wanted me talk
chief with some tips from studying from
last on the grid and then on that same
stream with a hundred thousand people
watching his game crashed how good was
that o screen I'm sorry Chad sorry chat
break okay let's break it off chat white
my game is broken the competition for
both these races was a mix of
professional drivers eSports
personalities like Sato kissed and red
eye and legit
celebrities like One Direction's Liam
Payne and golfer Ian Poulter now as you
might be able to guess from the level of
competition and all the craziness that
Norris got himself into these races were
more for entertainment than anything
else what they're trying to do is
entertain people like all we wanted to
do on Sunday night collectively is a set
of drivers and a set of organizers was
take everyone's minds away from what's
going on in the world for a couple of
hours to relieve some stress and tension
and bring some happiness for a few
people that miss their motor racing now
in saying that there are more serious
competitions that both Norris inverse
stop and will most likely compete in as
funny as it is that simracing is now
[ __ ] everywhere built-out leaves with
serious competition and $500,000 prize
pools have existed for years now NASCAR
and f1 have had pro leagues since 2015
Porsche has its own racing competitions
and iRacing which is a hardcore racing
sim that drivers actually practice on
has a bunch of different competitions so
then look at that then look at what 2k
diff with the MBA and putting that into
a sports league as well it isn't it just
a natural progression then to see f1 do
their thing and NASCAR do their thing
and actually by the way plenty of other
companies have done it as well Porsche
have their own virtual cups we had a
virtual LeMond 24 hour in the past we've
got Daytona 24-hour virtual staff these
things have been going on for a long
time so we've always had this kind of
sim racing system in the background and
I think you know eventually it kind of
came to the fore because of other sports
Sims having their own eSports leagues
which makes total sense and then the
more popular they've got they're also
popularized now because of what's been
going on
now this isn't 2 K or Madden a lot of f1
pros actually use these simulators to
practice for actual races and a lot of
these competitive scenes are used as
development programs for talented
eSports pros to maybe make a transition
to actual on track driving and it's not
like you can set up a fake dust2 B site
give a straw us and liquid real guns and
utility and tell them to have at it
jokes aside there's this sim racing
competitor igor Fraga who won a bunch of
tournaments back in 2017 as an eSports
competitor and then use these simulators
as a way to transition into f3 and
actual on track driving there's this
other dude Enzo Benito who races for red
Racing which is one of the world's most
popular sim racing teams
he went one-on-one with an actual f1
driver in real life driving real cars
and he beat his fastest lap I don't
think it's that much of a leap and when
you understand this right this is the
crucial part to understand that people
won't understand that before they've
seen this video and that is that the
high quality sim racing the guys that
playing things like race room and by
racing in particular an hour factor to
those guys those are so realistic the
simulations are so realistic in the game
them to be good in it you need to
understand everything there is about the
car but all of these things are
important and then on top of that track
understanding how to take to different
speeds of which gear which speed they
learn all of these things in the game
right there's a reason that landowner
smacks of statin use the games to learn
the tracks in real life so why why
wouldn't it be feasible that a really
talented sim racer could be really good
online I'm really good in sim racing in
understand all of these concepts and
then transfer them to the real world
they absolutely can now for Norris he's
actually growing on Twitch he's playing
escape from tarkov some rocket League
from time to time it's funny he's
actually becoming a real streamer so I
know the sudden popularity of this might
seem strange but it does make sense on
two fronts one Kovan 19 is keeping
everybody indoors and there's nothing to
watch and - this is one of the only
eSports that can actually replicate the
real-life thing that means 50,000 people
tuning in to watch IndyCar iRacing
eSports on NBC or Norse once again
having his game crash in front of a
hundred thousand people for a second
time
my gangs crashed and the NASCAR Pro
Invitational race was so popular that
Fox Sports and other cable channels are
gonna be broadcasting more events
nationally and maybe the coolest thing
about all of this is that a bunch of
people who were f1 and NASCAR fans have
now been introduced to eSports and they
probably would have watched eSports
otherwise and as easy as it is to poke
fun at this is a pretty cool showcase
for an eSport that's not csgo
League of Legends or Rainbow six siege I
think two summers ago now I went with
Darrell down to walk in Watkins Glen
which is down in a New York state I
believe correct me if I'm wrong and we
went to
watch a NASCAR race at Watkins Glen and
it was a [ __ ] blast dude like just
getting drinking Bud Light getting
shit-faced for two days straight getting
burnt all the hell sitting in the Sun
the racing is honestly like kind of
boring but it's just like being there in
that environment that I that was so much
fun for me